يقع في ألتنبرغ النمسا ، وهو
دير بنديكتيني به سرداب جميل بشكل غير عادي
، ويمتلئ الدير
بالمناطق المعروفة مثل
الغرفة الرخامية الرائعة والمكتبة والكنيسة الصغيرة
ودير القرون الوسطى ، ولكن المنطقة الوحيدة
التي تبرز هي
أقبية أقبية الأديرة غالبًا  منازل الموتى المظلمة تحت الأرض
ولكن هذا السرداب مشرق
وجدرانه مزينة بفن جميل.
قام الفنان النمساوي بول دروغو برسم اللوحات الجدارية التفصيلية
في القرن الثامن
عشر على مسافة
تبدو الصور مبهجة
ولكن الموت في التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
واحد  تتميز الحفرة بهيكل عظمي يحمل
سهمًا يستهدف الكروبين اثنين قُتلوا بالفعل
عند قدميه
، كما تم رسم صور معقدة للآلهة الرومانية في شكل هيكل عظمي
مع جداريات ضخمة
تم بناء دير Altenburg في عام 1140 ، ولكنه كان
موقعًا للعديد من الغزوات عبر
التاريخ في عام 1645  جعله هجوم سويدي
في حاجة إلى إصلاح شديد ولكن
على الرغم من هذه التجارب ، ظل الدير
نشطًا وهو فريد من نوعه
تجربة لكل الذين يأتون لمشاهدتها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]